ce panneau qui s'est engagé auprès des
grévistes on a une petite vidéo regardez
[Musique]
qui se vendent pour leur droit donc s'il
vous plaît j'aimerais que vous fassiez
du bruit à tous
c'est un peu l'éternel débat
est-ce que les gens connus ont raison de
s'engager politiquement de soutenir ou
pas
c'est voilà c'est son spectacle en plus
il fait il dit ce qu'il veut bon c'est
moi
que c'est sincère c'est au milieu du
concert comme ça
je trouve que c'est très bien de
s'engager quand le message paraît
crédible et lui c'est crédible vu tout
ce qu'il est ça résonne avec l'actualité
qu'il a toujours suivi de très près et
ça sincérité là moi ça m'émeut et ça me
touche il a eu raison
mais tu viens un concert au Stade de
France pour voir soprano chanter tu
viens pas pour le voir dire vas-y j'en
parle
politique je suis désolé sinon tu vas un
mythique de balance ou un meeting de
quelqu'un d'autre de gauche ou de droite
peu importe là on vient le voir chanter
on vient le voir écouter ces tubes qui
cartonne on vient pas entendre dire et
on embrasse les grévistes et on embrasse
regardez la vidéo tout le monde est
enchanté
c'est normal mais il y en a plein
sûrement qui ont défilé ou qui sont
contre
moi je suis d'accord avec Sacha tu vas
avoir un concert tu essaies de de pas
tout mélanger alors tu peux apporter je
pense peut-être un soutien quand il y a
quelque chose je dis pas que c'est
quelque chose de grave ce qui arrive de
nos jours c'est très compliqué mais s'il
y a eu un attentat ou des choses comme
ça là je pense que les gens doivent
aller voir un concert faut voilà
peut-être qu'il y avait une panne
musicale pendant un il fallait un
interlude et il a il a peut-être dit ça
comme ça mais non c'est pas vrai
c'est pas pour voilà c'est pour l'avoir
soit je suis d'accord avec sa chasse
c'est pour avoir un peu de d'humanité
autrement tu écoutes le disque dur il a
raison
j'ai fait de la musique et l'humanité je
la portais pas politiquement je la porte
si je peux me permettre Jean-Pascal
quand on chante la dictateur on va faire
un message politique derrière on n'est
pas très crédible on va pas se mentir
je vous ai beaucoup non Pascal
descendez un peu quand même
faut s'adresser au public par rapport à
la musique qu'on fait leur apporter des
trucs comme ça mais pas mélanger la
politique non ou salut les héros du
quotidien voilà c'est les affaires
oui mais comment vous faisiez pour
chanter entre deux chansons vous avez
deux chansons
alors j'ai fait plusieurs albums
on a tout vendre
moi j'ai mis oui parce que je pense que
effectivement c'est plutôt pas mal de
s'engager et effectivement pendant les
concerts là on est dans l'actualité donc
le type il parle avec son public
forcément à un moment donné il évoque ça
le seul truc que je trouve un peu
regrettable c'est que c'est souvent un
peu dégoût alors peut-être que comme dit
Gilles Louis lui il est peut-être un
petit peu plus légitime dans ce genre de
débat mais quand on voit par exemple
Léonardo Dicaprio qui nous parle de
l'écologie avec une empreinte carbone
qui est démentiel
démentiel franchement Marion Cotillard
qui est là très très dans la cause
pareil écologique trucs on connaît la
vie qui est là très voilà bobo je me
lave pas les cheveux
pour moi ça c'est déplacé c'est se fout
de la gueule du monde en fait clairement
quoi bah pour soprano oui pourquoi pas
alors s'engager dans l'actualité et puis
à s'engager auprès d'un pour une
élection ça c'est très dangereux en
politique très dangereux d'une manière
générale les artistes sont quand même
intérêt à être dans le sens du vent et
plutôt de gauche parce que je suis
désolé il y a imaginer un artiste
pendant un concert qui aurait dit ouais
super la réforme des retraites
il y a forcément dans les milliers
d'artistes certains qui est quand même
il y a que il y a 30 %
ça peut être très dangereux une prise de
position et c'est toujours un petit peu
dans le même sens donc c'est voilà c'est
bien qu'il le fasse mais c'est pas hyper
courant